along the sea pic River in Papua New
Guinea a group of initiates is about to
enter the final stage of a long and
arduous ritual for six weeks they've
been locked away in the hut known as the
spirit house they range in age from 11
years old to more than 30 there is no
set age for the right but no one can
have full status as a man until he's
done it and the hardest part is still to
come the initiate will be scarred with
the mark of the crocodile the meaning of
the crocodile is ancestral for us to
book these cuts tell everyone to
recognize local has initiated mm if
these young sea pig men can suffer
through the pain of being scarred
they'll be strong enough to shoulder the
burdens of adulthood but Dixon one of
the initiates knows such strength may
come at a steep price
the last clue flaw in the last group of
initiatives they had one that I did come
up so this makes us afraid let's lay
making plate for it it is the morning of
the ritual
inside the spirit house the heroine
cutting is about to begin
the initiate um khals hold them down as
tribal cutters wield the razor's the men
can chew a leaf that has the effect of a
strong drink but they get no anesthetic
to dull the pain the cutters work
diligently making slash after slash in
the initiate tender skin the men's
bodies are racked with pain through the
long excruciating day Fidelis fights
against the agonizing pain but his uncle
can dari
knows well but pain is critical to the
initiation ami must come up mine in
order to become a man he must experience
pain for he'll remember it later on and
he'll be able to endure whatever
troubles he faces in the future
finally the cutting is over physically
and emotionally exhausted the initiate
search area inside to recover they have
their hundreds of wounds treated but the
touch of a feather is all they're
throbbing aching bodies can bear the
cutting may be finished but they're not
out of danger yet for Westerners the
biggest concern would be infection but
the SI phix actually encourage a
controlled infection smoke irritates the
raw wounds while clay and tree oil limit
the inflammation in the days ahead
this process will turn these cuts into
the highly prized marks of the crocodile
for the next two weeks the men go
through the same routine they gingerly
wash their open wounds according fresh
pain in the cold water if I didn't wash
these cuts they wouldn't come up the way
I want it's a process where we have to
keep doing this for a week or so if you
didn't do this and you left them they
become big swords and I wouldn't get the
effect you want
finally the initiative outside
presentative survivors and true men
ready to assume their new roles as
leaders their scars are a badge of honor
and a sign they've completed their
painful journey to manhood